what's up everybody how was lunch
I didn't eat lunch and I down some cold
brew so we'll see how this goes so first
before I get started I want to tell you
a little bit about myself so my name is
Neville Medora my main thing I focus on
right now is copywriting course
misspelled with two K's and I'm also a
part of a bunch of other companies and
I'm going to tell you how this came
about and part of a couple things
appSumo the hustle real savvy pink java
a bunch of other things and the way that
i got all these cushy gigs where i
barely do any work yet somehow bring in
an income is through building a machine
that does most of it for me I am a super
lazy person and I still do work and
stuff but what I noticed in the
beginning was that every time I did
something I would have this dip and I
can explain that so the very first way
that I got like any notoriety online was
I started a personal blog called Nev
blog in 2004 so actually November 17th
2004 is when it actually started and
back then like no one made money from
blogs it was like for like 16 year olds
talking about their feelings it was kind
of a joke to have a blog so when my
friends found out I had a blog called
Nev blog they just told this day call me
Nev walk all the time and it was never
blog type fine but dot blog spot.com and
it was called nevels financial blog and
the tagline was super cheesy was
tracking the road to financial success
from the age of 22 and and I just stupid
college kid I was a bit of a hustler I
was doing all sorts of stuff on the side
and I was like how do I track all the
money that I'm making and without using
expensive software and stuff I thought
well a blog is a nice chronological way
to document everything so I put up all
the assets I had and at 22 I thought it
was hella rich like I had ten thousand
plus in cash and then like a stock
account I thought I was super rich and
compared to my friends I was and so I
started listing out everything I did and
then also how I made the money so
I owned a rave company at the time I
started a little a what I called an
agency but it was really just me making
webpage it's called res you might so I
made resume websites resume I thought it
was kind of cool and so I started
publishing on this blog regularly and lo
and behold people just somehow started
finding out about it I didn't tell
anyone it just just started taking off
and so I started I was encouraged by
this I got that little taste of like
someone's reading so I started posting
more of my money and in more detail and
just a short year later I had $26,000
and I was like oh this is this kind of
cool putting my stuff out there gets me
attention and it keeps me accountable it
makes me want to make more money so I'd
list out everything I made for my rave
company and I guess January 2005 I made
five hundred and two dollars in profit
it's just helpful to see that stuff
there my change jar had thirty dollars
in it so I did all these different
things and started listening in right
and and noticed this one it says water
experiment down there five dollars so
here's what that was I started doing way
crazier stuff than any other financial
blogger out there most financial
bloggers were doing stuff like I'm gonna
do a money experiment and they go sell
their a computer monitor on eBay and I
was like dude that's like it's not
really an experiment so I wanted to shut
down all the haters on my site that
would be like you have to have money to
make money so I was like I bet I could
get a homeless dude to make money on the
side of the road and I got this guy
named Barry who has a serious crack
addiction by the way to to sell a bunch
of bottled water that I bought for five
bucks and we did this we did this like
10 times with Barry and other homeless
guys and I published this and and this
is like 2005-2006 so this was not
revolutionary but it was super
interesting for back then right so this
was kind of like a weird thing my
parents were like what why are you why
are you even doing this like what is the
purpose of this and it got me a little
bit of attention which was kind of cool
so you get a big boost of traffic and it
feels really good it makes you want to
do more of that stuff so then I did even
more stuff one of the ways I would
network with like really rich people is
a crash
parties I had some mentors and they
would tell me about these crazy parties
that they're going to with like Michael
Dell and Lance Armstrong and I bought a
crappy suit for a hundred bucks from kgs
Men's Wearhouse and would crash all of
them and would have to blend in and so
the top left one that's the Prime
Minister of Malaysia I we I'm not gonna
say I stole something
but yadda yadda yadda we surpassed an
FBI background check to get in the room
with 25 press members for that one and
then and that's Lam strong strong the
CEO of Gibson guitars
there's Herb Kelleher I knew he loved
whiskey and smoking so I bought
cigarettes and booze and took a picture
with him and I'd post all these exploits
online is like borderline sometimes
illegal stuff and this was another one
like my parents didn't talk to me for
like a week after I did this I this
homeless thing kept coming up with
people and I was like what if I just go
homeless and see what happens like
what's the worst that could happen so
for four nights five days I like when
homeless I grew up my beard that was me
at the end like I truly felt homeless in
that picture it was not fun and then I
did these mini experiments like I bummed
money and bought alcohol and got
absolutely house off this bottle of
cheap Kentucky Bourbon or whatever and
the next day I woke up in a park covered
in ants and and I'd published this stuff
online and it actually worked
this is the this is the Wall Street
Journal in Russia business section
someone sent that to me and it says
never blog up there somewhere and I was
getting featured in publications and I
was like it's kind of awesome like
that's how my parents found out about it
I was in the New York Times and one of
their friends was like Neville's in the
New York Times congratulations and
they're like what and they saw that I
was publishing money that I made online
which for Indian parents is like super
taboo but here's the thing all this
stuff all these crazy experiments doing
way more than other people would do and
here's the result after ten years never
block traffic like for real was just
flat there was roughly 15,000 you know
average per month coming to the site but
it was kind of
disappointing because if you do
something for 10 years and you're in the
same place like I don't know I think you
just suck at it or it's that's not very
encouraging right so what would happen
was I would do these crazy experiments I
would do the bottled water experiment
and my traffic would spike up but then
you have to top it right so there's like
a dip that happens and the first day you
get 30% less traffic and then 50% on top
of that and you're back to normal then I
would do I go homeless and I got a bunch
of traffic and then it would go down now
I crash a party him to go up and then it
would go down and it was it's like a
treadmill it's just like in place I
could never grow past a certain size
despite putting so much time and effort
into it and then I was like wait a
second
here's the problem I put out a piece of
content and then it dipped it goes up
and then it dips and then I have to wait
a while before I do something else crazy
and it goes up and then it dips and then
people who saw one experiment didn't see
all the other things that I did
so I implemented an autoresponder for
the next big website I actually made and
here are the results of that so this is
copywriting course traffic over the same
course of period as net blog same ten
year span or whatever that is and that
one went up into the right and it's
still going right and it's actually it's
not comparable this is actually like
four times more traffic or something
like that and the difference between net
vlog and copywriting course was from the
very beginning when it became a company
on January 1st 2015 I implemented an
autoresponder an email capture or
contact capture on every single page
that there was that was the biggest
mistake I ever made with Neve blog and
after ten years it's still in the exact
same place because of that because just
people see the stuff and then they leave
so what's an autoresponder and why
should you implement it for really any
business you have if you're doing
something online it's just a piece of
software that delivers an email for you
so on this day it delivers this email on
it delivers this email on this day and
so forth that's all it is it's really
really really simple but profoundly
game-changing so with Neff blog my
personal blog people read the content be
like wow this guy's crazy and then I
don't know they just leave they just
they just leave and unless they type in
my name to their browser they would
never find me again or if they just
happen to stumble upon me otherwise I
had no control over that audience so
never blog was a personal blog that
image that funny oh cool nice so never
log was a personal blog so it it wasn't
my main source of revenue so I never
minded that dip like it was kind of like
okay whatever that's just the nature of
things but if you have a business and
you're putting out content all the time
and you go up and then down up and then
down up and then down and you're not
growing that's literally just throwing
money in the toilet for your marketing
efforts
so with an autoresponder they come read
your content and assuming that you get
their info that you're successful at
that you can send them more content and
more content and more content
occasionally sell them something more
content and you can annoy them forever I
prefer to educate and you know give them
good stuff so the reason you're all here
today is because the hustle got your
email address 100% of you I'm assuming
that's how you got here for the most
part it's just this simple process and
people tend to still put up content till
this day and not spend any time trying
to get the customers contact info and
here's everything I used to build my own
machine it's really simple I use the
sumo comm tool that's just an email
pop-up tool it's really that simple you
just install that as WP engine for my
hosting of WordPress I use leadpages for
some landing pages and any email stuff
and then Infusionsoft I use that for my
autoresponder but you can use Aweber
MailChimp convertkit infusions they're
all the same thing
right it's just an autoresponder now how
can you build your own machine either
for an existing business or a current
one I'll take you inside of mine so this
is inside of my Infusionsoft I apologize
the things are so small I'll zoom in in
a second
but if you see what's going on this is
about 64 of my posts on copywriting
course which is now like the largest
copywriting blog and there's about 100
posts total that's it 100 pieces of
content if not if maybe like 95 or
something this is 64 of them and what
you are seeing is each post goes people
sign up for the forum and it either
throws them into two buckets that
they're an existing member in which case
it does nothing because I already got
them on the email list and then the
second bucket is that it keeps them into
that autoresponder
so this is an example of a download I
have at the end of every post if you
haven't noticed my style of drawing and
stuff is very very cheesy and I like it
so this is at the end of a how to get
your Facebook post seen okay it talks
about how to game Facebook and I make
this cheesy looking ebook download thing
and people sign up to this they they
want the whole post to either copy or
read or share with their colleagues in
PDF for Google Doc format so they just
click that they enter their email
address and bam the machine takes over I
don't have to do anything it doesn't
matter that the machine it has them now
they've got them so let's zoom in on
just like a cross-section of this to
just show you an example of how the
machine works so let's look at the top
left over there it says writer's block
right and then there's old member and
then start KK sequence start copywriting
course sequence and and that's the only
one we're worried about the ones that
are highlighted now the start KK
sequence on this one has zero so that
means in this month a couple people
three people or a couple people have
signed up to the writer's block post but
no new people have signed up so okay the
machine is relatively ineffective their
second one email open rates download
zero people nothing but then the next
one
the copywriters salary one look at that
seven of my old members signed up so who
cares about that then twenty three new
people signed up so I didn't do anything
for that people just found me through
links SEO whatever you have it and
signed up and then it goes through an
autoresponder and then another post got
fifty people the recurring revenue
calculator looks like fifty people
downloaded that this month if you total
all of these up this is just one this is
sixteen posts that adds up to three
hundred and thirty three new subscribers
and this is just a small cross-section
there's about a hundred posts so every
month without having actually done
anything like if I get hit by a bus
these still get collected which is
pretty great so here's an example of
what I'm talking about
this is a how to become a copywriter
post a lot of people ask this question
so I made an article on it and it gets
people
about a little over a year it's got a
hundred and five thousand unique
pageviews generally historically overall
site-wide through the years my
conversion rate has been about five
percent of people will sign up to my
website from just random traffic so
that's about five thousand plus new
people of those five percent buy
something at an average rate of five
hundred dollars each that's about a
hundred thousand something dollars in
revenue that I didn't do anything for I
had no involvement from it whatsoever I
made the content once and then it just
repeats and repeats and repeats and
repeats ad nauseam and for a hundred
thousand something in revenue in one
year here's all that was that I had to
do I just made that little once again
one of those cheese a little ebook
download things I said I know this post
is hella long so download this post and
read it later that was it and all these
people downloaded it and then I got
their email and then the autoresponder
took over I'll show you that in a second
too so here's another one this this
one's not even about copywriting it's
called how to scam people for money so
this is like a humorous piece I wanted
to write I thought it was kind of like a
joke but it actually kind of took off
and look a hundred and sixty thousand
unique page views in about a year a
little over a year so that equated to
about eight thousand new people and four
hundred and four customers that is
roughly two hundred something thousand
dollars worth of revenue I had no
involvement in and did nothing for so
even if I was dead this would have
happened which is super cool and for
that one all I did I didn't even make
the little book I just said send me
emails I said you can use these
psychological tricks for good or evil
your choice sign up to the email list
and start learning every week that's all
if you just add something like that at
the bottom of every post you too can
have this so when I talked about the
Machine this is literally what it is
this is a screenshot of what the machine
is it's it's just an autoresponder it's
just laid out so it looks kind of cool
so it's not that revolutionary Aweber
MailChimp anything you use will do this
okay so people sign up and then between
6 a.m. and 9 p.m. it sends them that
first email
this email will teach you how to write
better in two days at 7:00 a.m. and
we'll send them that next one how
copywriting changed my life
two days later the email script that
changed my life
so the first three don't sell anything
they just give good copywriting
information because that's what they're
usually looking for the second to the
fourth and fifth emails try to sell a
digital product that's the only time I
sell in this entire sequence and then
from there on it just gives them good
information again but this is all
automated so once someone goes in that
top it goes boop boop boop and just
keeps on going
and I don't have to do anything and then
for four to six months they get more
content and it's very helpful stuff it's
it's not just trying to sell them
anything so the first one is a street
advertising experiment where we we redid
a sandwich board for a shoe hospital and
I got 50% more walkins and we don't even
get them to the site it just sends them
everything in the email kind of like the
hustle does and then the next one it
will go to copywriting books my favorite
copywriting books
copywriting exercises how to write in a
proper tone of voice etc etc etc and
this is all on the machine which is
super cool so here's why it's awesome to
build a machine I make that word passive
income because it zooms that you do
nothing but it really does take out the
sharp edges of your work so I don't have
to be doing crazy stuff every day I
don't have to be writing articles every
day in fact I write maybe one or two a
month now and that's just enough the
autoresponder does all the rest of the
work so here's me and my buddy Noah just
chilling in San Juan this year and I was
just reading most of the time I was
reading the Judd Apatow book the whole
time that was my goal for the whole trip
and I did a little bit of work here and
there our to hear their every day but I
didn't have to do anything this is us
just chilling on the beach and yeah you
don't really pick petrova but uh and
then also here I love coming to San
Francisco actually live in Austin but
during the summers and stuff I come over
here because it's way better cool people
etc and I don't have to do that much
while I'm here because the machine is
taking care of most of the lifting the
machine is currently nurturing twenty
thousand clients or something
I don't even know it doesn't matter to
me system machine I get to hang out at
the hustle with Gus and Sid I threw a
Conor McGregor fight party and all
during that the machine was working and
working and working and working and
working which allows me to do you know
more of what I like to do so there's
only one Nevel
there's only me but I'm up here talking
I can't do anything else right now but
when you build a machine out like this
you get many levels so that guy sends
the first email that guy sends a second
email the third one and you can clone
yourself and so if you want to build
your own machine I'll leave you with
this the only thing you have to do is
collect info on every page build a
machine that removes the dips in the
business where you put something out and
then it dips just remove that and build
a machine that works for you and then
you two could be hella lazy like me
thank you very much I appreciate